es el principal tema en los titulares de
este martes en reinounido luego de vivir
la noche más calurosa que se ha
registrado hasta el momento los
británicos se despertaron preparándose
para un calor de 40 grados celsius
temperaturas nunca antes vistas en el
país la ola de calor ha hecho que los
habitantes de las ciudades huyan en masa
a las zonas costeras las playas de todo
el país están inundadas con miles de
personas desesperadas por mantenerse
frescas este es un buen llamado para que
todos nosotros entendamos que es
necesario hacer frente a los costos del
cambio climático hemos estado alertando
en la comunidad científica así que
espero que no solo nos adaptemos sino
que preparemos nuestras ciudades para
hacerle frente a estas olas de calor que
cada vez son más frecuentes
la gente no es la única que está
luchando contra el calor el sistema de
transporte también está haciéndole
frente a la situación los días de
temperaturas abrasadoras han provocado
importantes interrupciones en los trenes
los operadores de trenes han pedido a
las personas que viajen sólo si es
absolutamente necesario
en el tren elevado si no está tan mal el
aire acondicionado no funciona y
funciona en invierno no puedo creerlo
pero si ayer fue lento llegar a casa así
que hoy saldré un poco antes si el
ministro de transportes británico grant
shapps advirtió que podrían pasar años
antes de que las infraestructuras del
país puedan actualizarse completamente
para hacer frente a las altas
temperaturas un proceso que ahora tendrá
que acelerarse